anschließend weil man darf nicht
vergessen allein deutschen und hat 2015
über eine million flüchtlinge
aufgenommen ganz europa ist dieser
furchtbare satz von angela merkel im
kopf mit wir schaffen das die selbst
lieder noch mehr wissen will wie die
motten das licht angezogen haben und und
den flüchtlingsströmen noch mehr belebt
haben und damals darf nicht vergessen
sind ja hauptsächlich im gegen alle in
allen erzählungen damals hauptsächlich
junge männer gekommen über 80 prozent
waren waren junge männer aus überwiegend
islamischen ländern jetzt muss man sagen
kommen ja aus der ukraine kommen ja
christliche frauen mit kindern das ist
ja ein anderes integrationsproblem
sondern das sind erstens unsere nachbarn
wir müssen ja nicht die ganze welt
retten aber wenn wir sagen immer hilfe
vor ort immer predigen mann soll vor ort
helfen dann sind wir natürlich in der in
der in der lage und zielt auch gefordert
den ukrainern zu helfen und ich finde da
schon am pc verzeihen sie mir ein land
wie deutschland wie viele einwohner
haben sind über 80 millionen oder
diskutiert über die probleme 300.000
ukrainische frauen und kinder aufnehmen
zu können und zwar genau diejenigen
leute die 2015 kommen die über eine
million islamistischen männer schaffen
wir also da müssen wir noch nicht haben
kann dann ist das bis dahin sollten am
esstisch das würde ich an cannes zu
beschauen allein die ersten drei monate
das sie dass dieses jahres ist ja der
flüchtlingsstrom um 89 prozent in der ju
gestiegen das sind die neuen zahlen der
union und die die ausgenommen der
ukraine ist die stärkste gruppe sind
130000 afghanen nach europa gekommen in
den ersten drei monaten das sehen die
zahlen und es gibt halt mittlerweile
auch und ich sage das jetzt überspitzt
sehr viele
ukraine anscheinend wenn man sich auf
den bahnhöfen wenn ich mal aufmachen das
soll nicht die kein kind von meinungen
aber dann ist
ihre zeit ist man aber nur eine zusage
muss ihnen die tausenden flüchtlinge die
bieten lukaschenko an wer weiß wo sich
polnischen grenze gehabt und sind die
noch an der grenze oder sind
mittlerweile schon symbol über den umweg
der ukraine sind mittlerweile in
deutschland wo sind denn die kein mensch
mehr von den großen von flüchtlingsstrom
über weißrussland das sind dinge die man
könnte man vielleicht nachfragen und es
ist dann
man will ja niemanden was unterstellen
aber warum gerade rot grün nicht für die
registrierung ist von flüchtlingen muss
man muss mit grünen erklären da muss man
sich nicht wundern ich finde aber den
satz wir schaffen das war merkel den
finde ich nicht schlimm ich finde ich
finde es schlimm wenn sie mal ein ganz
frühes zugelassen habe das war der
fehler nicht dass wir gesagt wir
schaffen es tatsächlich hat etwas
geschafft das in ganz europa gut aber es
kann mit modernen einmal stand er ein
falscher zungenschlag rein nämlich dass
wir problematisieren dass wir hier
jungen frauen helfen und kindern helfen
dass es gerade nicht der fall aber wir
wissen dass wenn viele menschen zu uns
kommen dass es voll probleme gibt und
die müssen eben frühzeitig gelöst und
zum thema registrierungs gab diese woche
im gespräch mit der bundespolizei die
bestätigen dass es funktionieren würde
also da ist in den letzten jahren dann
auch einiges nachgeholt worden wir haben
auf jeden fall gesehen dass das thema
großen redebedarf hatte ich glaube es
werden wir noch öfter bei 48 haben und
damit deswegen habe ich sie geradezu
rüde unterbrochen damit sie genug zeit
auch für ihr thema noch haben bis ende
schloss die mischung zeit aber
nein aber grundsätzlich geht es darum
frank walter steinmeier deutschland
präsent hat sich diese woche
entschuldigt für die falsche russland
politik der letzten zwei jahrzehnte
putin hat er 2000 russland übernommen
und damals wurde auch mit put in einem
anderen team versucht eine friedliche
koexistenz eine wirtschaftliche
koexistenz ein miteinander zu schaffen
eine lehre aus dem kalten krieg das
europa getrennt hatte ich komme selber
aus österreich wie waren andere an der
am eisernen vorhang berlin war eine
getrennte statt und wir müssen uns jetzt
einfach anschauen wofür soll das
entschuldigen dass man es versucht hat
man musste sich dafür entschuldigen dass
man es nicht versucht hat man sollte
sich vielmehr sollte sich europas
politiker das sind alle regierungen
gefragt dafür entschuldigen dass wir es
nicht geschafft haben in einem falschen
globalisierungs waren uns energieautark
zu machen dass wir rechtzeitig in der
energiewende gebaut haben dass wir alle
unsere armee abgebaut haben ich finde es
sehr spannend dass diejenigen die bisher
gegen die wehrpflicht waren die gegen
die bundeswehr waren die gegen die
aufrüstung waren diejenigen die tram
belächelt haben wo er die nato staaten
gezwungen hat zwingen wollte aufzurüsten
endlich einmal die verpflichtungen zu
nehmen diejenigen die dafür waren krieg
mit wattebällchen zu führen und sollten
wir haben kann kommen zu nennen kriegen
mehr in europa das die jene die größten
kriegstreiber und truppen und waffen in
die ukraine schränken wollen sondern
europa hängt mittlerweile am schoß
zipfel der amerikaner aber sancho panza
des don quijote beiden und wenn man
sieht dass zb der frühere pazifist
habeck die grünen haben ja wahlkampf
gemacht noch gegen waffenlieferungen in
kriegsführende staaten jetzt zum end
unrechtsregimen nach katar pilgert und
sich dort so tief vor dem scheich
verbeugt der homosexuelle verfolgt der
palästinenser quält und habe ich machte
einen kutter wenn man sie hoffen muss
dass das seine füße gewaschen hat also
wir brauchen wieder ein starkes europa
wir brauchen ein starkes europa wir
brauchen ein geeintes europa und wir
brauchen ein aufgerüstetes europa wenn
menschen und machtmensch wird putin
verstehen nur stärker und direktheit
absolute zustimmung beim letzten satz
putin versteht nur stärke aber ich würde
widersprechen bei der these dass wir es
vor einigen jahren mit einem anderen
putin zu tun gehabt haben das wird uns
glaube ich jetzt mittlerweile klar dass
jetzt über sehr lange zeit dieser krieg
auch vorbereitet worden ist es ab 2014
begonnen als wir auch nicht bereit waren
als deutschland entsprechend schärfere
sanktionen zu machen und nach ein paar
monaten dann auch wieder während zum zum
daily business übergegangen sind und von
daher ist eine entschuldigung eines
politikers muss man immer fragen was
bringt das am schluss aber wenn es dazu
führt dass wir uns eingestehen dass wir
hier eine falsche politik gemacht habe
dann finde ich das richtig und wenn es
dann insbesondere einer derjenigen macht
die ja zu dieser russland connection der
spd dazu gehören wie schröder schwesig
und andere klingbeil dann fand ich das
zumindest gut dass das passiert ist also
ich halte es für freistaat
parteipolitisches kleingeld zu wechseln
auf unsere konservative österreichische
bundeskanzler schüssel weilen in
aufsichtsräten sowie auch zwei
sozialdemokratische bundeskanzler putin
hat die die alte die abgehalfterten alt
politiker europas gesammelt wie andere
briefmarken und sich aber auch jetzt
gemerkt dass ihm das auch nichts bringt
er hat einfach man kann dazu stehen wie
man will man kann sagen die nato hat
sich erweitert gegen ihr ging entgegen
dem versprechen in russland gegeben hat
russland hat die ukraine ihr können
diskutieren das sind ja neue dokumente
einmal ganz kurz sebastian geist schon
reingehen weil mit der nato-erweiterung
da gibt es ja viele berichte die schon
gegen diese russische propaganda wie
viele sagen er sind ja eigentlich hatten
wir ja der der ukraine weißrussland als
die ukraine ihre atomwaffen aufgegeben
hat hat man sowohl wissen also gegen
russland martin gegeben was ist daraus
geworden ich möchte das ganze auch etwas
grundsätzlich betrachten da treten also
politiker an und sagen sie möchten
gewählt werden in ein öffentliches amt
in unserem staat für uns alle
verantwortung tragen so ja auch eher
steinmeier ja und jetzt einfach nur und
man hat uns wir hängen nicht nämlich
nicht wie einfach nur an den amerikanern
wir hängen jetzt auch am russen gas
warum aufgrund von politischen
entscheidungen die unsere führung
getroffen hat ja also schröder hat das
natürlich ganz massiv forciert merkel
später aber genauso so und jetzt jetzt
haben wir den laden hier quasi vor die
wand gefahren jetzt haben wir auch eine
situation wie sie jetzt in der ukraine
ist haben wir dazu beigetragen
da muss man sagen das ist ein kiefer ein
grund sich zum einen zu entschuldigen
sondern so etwas da sind andere schon
für sehr viel weniger zurückgetreten
sogar insofern also absolut fairen wert
gefunden ein rücktritt sei der einzige
ausweg aus menschenrechtskonforme
qatargas wo man nur die kleinigkeit dazu
sagen muss dass weder die katari die die
kompetenz haben und die das volumen
dieses gas zu liefern erst ab 2024 der
anlage so gebaut haben oder die
klitzekleine kleinigkeit dass
deutschland als ein flüssiggas aufnimmt
keinen einzigen flüssiggas terminal hat
und wenn man am flughafen berlin sid wie
unter einer textilfabrik
deutschen hätten sie es jetzt besser
gefunden wenn herr steinmeier
zurückgetreten ist empfinden sie
vielleicht auch einfach die
entschuldigung als na ja wozu ich hätte
mich nicht entschuldigt weil ich glaube
das ist damals richtig war ich glaube
dass putin sich in den letzten fünf
jahren zudem entwickelt hat langsam aber
doch was er jetzt ist ein die alle
militärdiktator dass das muss man ganz
nicht ganz ganz eingestehen also ich
habe mit putin vor ungefähr 15 jahren
mal abend gegessen und da war ein sehr
konversation sehr angenehm sehr klug
sehr sehr analytisch sehr vernünftig
denkender mensch man kann niemanden
hinein sehen auch wir alle wissen jetzt
nicht ob und wie viele vermuten
durchgeknallt ist aber einfach knallhart
ist
gegen wladimir putin funktioniert bei
keinem von uns wir können alle nur raten
sein engstes umfeld weiß es ja nicht das
würde er auch anscheinend ausgetauscht
aber jetzt sitzen wir halt auf der
gasleitung und es kann keine lösung sein
steinmeier sagt zum beispiel aus dem 2
dass wir noch dass wir jetzt eine
leitung haben durch die ukraine
kriegsgebiet und sagen nein damit wir
uns jeder wie sie also etwa mit
einer auch eine frage an frau berge und
zwar hatte der besitzer gerade gesagt
militär diktator zucchini putin ist
hätte steinmeier sich entschuldigen
müssen ja oder nein
also ich wundere mich dass so dass
dieses wedding dass es wirklich ein
kriegsverbrecher ist dass das meines
erachtens können sicher sagen
parteipolitik hin oder her aber dass es
von uns nur so deutlich angesprochen
wird und dass es trotzdem auch bei der
spitze der spd und auch bei vielen in
der spd da ist sich immer so nebulös
herum geschmuggelt wird weil man immer
noch eine beißhemmung hat diesbezüglich
und was in dem zusammenhang auch nicht
geht ist dass jemand wie gerhard
schröder immer noch von uns alimentiert
wird das geht einfach nicht da muss man
ganz klar sagen da muss die spd eine
reißleine ziehen sein absolutes no go
das verhalten nicht nur die maria mutter
gottes hände von seiner ehefrau also
eine farce die da stattfindet sondern er
bekommt geld von den deutschen
steuerzahlerinnen und steuerzahlern die
spd zieht keine reis landes haben es
irgendwie hat schultertasche aus dem
fenster entfernt das reicht aber nicht
und da erwarte ich einfach von einer
partei die die bundeskanzler stellt auch
eine komplette distanzierung vom
altkanzler für den man sich wirklich
jeden tag stemmen muss nur eines noch in
der geschichte das ist ja alles schön
und schröder aber schröder ist dagegen
es geht darum
töten wir mit den sanktionen durch das
carven die rheingas in bar machen töten
wir unsere industrie frieren wir und was
kommt danach lassen wir aus den dritten
weltkrieg erschienen ich glaube weiß
daher schröder das aller geringste
problem das wir alle haben unter
schröder wird sich das mit seinem konto
sein gegenüber selbst aber wenn sie das
sagen warum soll man sich dann dafür
nicht entschuldigen das verstehe ich
sehe mir auch gesagt hat einen anderen
putin kennengelernt oder gedacht oder er
hat ihn für anders gehalten aber jetzt
sind sie ja eigentlich selber der
meinung okay der mann wurde unterschätzt
warum darf man sich nicht dafür
entschuldigen das ist ein ganz gute
frage stimmt vielleicht hat sich putin
verändert wer weiß das boot im jahr
waren es steigerte im jahr 2009
steinmeiers entschuldigt was meiner
meinung nach zu dieser zeit richtig war
man hat versucht man musste die
koexistenz mit mit russland suchen weil
russland ist ein gewaltiges land ist ein
wichtiger wirtschaftspartner und es ist
immer besser jemanden zu umarmen als das
in der selber will ein